vous avez peut-être entendu parler d'une
expérience appelée le Russian sleep
experiment qui a été mené dans les
années 40 on avait enfermé C prisonniers
russes dans une pièce qui était
régulièrement remplie d'un gaz qui les
tenait éveillés et on leur avait fait
croire que sils arrivaient à ne pas
dormir pendant 30 jours il serait libéré
l'expérience elle avait dû être arrêtée
parce que les pauvres Bou soit ils
étaient devenus complètement fous soit
ils s'étaient automutilé soit ils
étaient morts soit les trois et ben le
Russian sleep experiment l'expérience du
sommeil russe c'est une creepy pasta une
nouille flippante en fait c'est juste
une légende urbaine qu'on se raconte
autour d'un feu de camp avant de se
faire découper si on vit dans un film
d'horreur c'est une légende urbaine